avec philippe haas au délégué diocésain
au dialogue interreligieux pour les
questions politiques et sociétales
rattaché à la basilique de nice bonjour
philippe assauts merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous sur rt france votre réaction
tout d'abord à l'injonction du conseil
d'état qui donne au premier ministre
trois jours pour revoir sa copie c'était
une décision attendue car de bon sens
le juge des référés liberté puisque
aucune activité n'avait été soumise à
une limitation indépendamment des
superficies des des lieux d'accueil
c'est ce qu'a dit conseil d'état c'est
le mot disproportionnée au regard des de
la condition des enjeux de santé
publique exactement ça veut dire que
pour vous les églises ou ou tout autre
lieu de culte
d'ailleurs qui sont concernés aussi par
cette jauge ne sont pas des lieux de
contamination contrairement à ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre pas du tout les
évêques de france ont bien stipulé que
les mesures étaient à appliquer pour
lutter contre les contaminations
éventuelles et la propagation du comique
19 les évêques de france ont invité à
observer les décisions de l'état tout en
poupe en se portant devant le juge des
référé liberté devant une mesure qui
défiait le bon sens dans une chapelle de
20 personnes m 30 personnes c'est
absolument contradictoire avec ses
précautions de responsabilité humaine
citoyenne et chrétienne mais m trente
personnes dans une cathédrale clients
disposent de lille place c'est
complètement aberrant aussi donc cette
nouvelle est accueillie comme une mesure
de bon sens et pas du tout comme l'umih
dans d'autres des nécessités de
prophylaxie en matière de contamination
possible départ le coc vidéo
comment est ce qu'on a pu arriver à une
telle absurdité
n'y at il pas eu des consultations avec
le premier ministre avant d'imposer
cette mesure
deux choses je crois que la première
chose et je le disais une question de
bon sens et je doute que ceux qui ont
préparé cette mesure et de jauge à 30
personnes soit jamais rentré dans des
églises chapelles à lure où ma vie
deuxième chose nous constatons une un
des shows ou dialogue et de débats entre
les différentes instances notamment
l'état et la représentation de l'église
catholique en france et ses taux au
dialogue ouvert et sensée et aux débats
que les évêques de france appellent de
façon à ne pas avoir recourir à la voie
judiciaire
mémé pouvoir régler dans le dialogue et
le débat
ces questions puisque il est assez rare
de voir les effectivement cette
communauté catholique protester contre
le gouvernement ce soir le premier
ministre reçoit lé représentant des
évêques de france
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est dit
et vers quoi s'achemine-t-on alors la
situation dans les villes de france et
chez les catholiques de france est plus
contrastée de ce que l'on dit il ne
s'agit pas d'une europe opposition
unanime
il ya effectivement une revendication
liée à la nécessité fondamentale et les
chrétiens catholiques sentent de pouvoir
vivre et non pas à citer vivent là mais
c'est le mystère du charisme maintenant
je ne peux pas vous dire c'est que les
premiers ministres et la représentation
des évêques de france se sont dit
effectivement il y aura un communiqué
probablement à la fois du premier
ministre et de la conférence des évêques
de france
l issue de cette réunion nous nous
espérons une jauge limitée non pas 30
personnes mais
à trente constant de l'occupation des
locaux d'autant que nous volume
religieux sont largement imposés alors
c'est une période où il y aura je
n'imagine beaucoup de fidèles puisque ce
week-end les catholiques fait le premier
week-end de l'avent
c'était essentiel pour vous justement à
cette période que cette jauge soit levé
que ces restrictions soient levés
il ya la période
nous entrons dans la nouvelle année
liturgique et dans le temps de l'avent
qui nous prépare à au mystère de noël
c'est donc un itinéraire fondamentale
spirituelle et sociale des chrétiens car
les chrétiens ne vivent pas leur foi
isolé de manière individuelle mais en
communauté dans l'église ça c'est 1 1
comme des points deuxièmement il y à ce
que l'état doit garantir au titre de la
loi du 9 décembre 1905 de séparation des
églises et de l'état et la liberté de
l'exercice des cultes
cependant nous comprend bien je vous en
prie finissait et nous comprenons bien
que dans le cadre la pandémie on y lit
et des mesures ils soient demandés et
les évêques de france ont d'ailleurs
proposé un protocole sanitaire pour la
réouverture aux dans une jauge
raisonnable tout à fait exigeant
dernière question très court le gone au
conseil d'état a parlé d'une atteinte
grave à la liberté de culte cette
question d'atteinte aux libertés et
hautement à la une de l'actualité
vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat le
président de la république en 2018
devant la conférence des évêques de
france a déclaré que le lien entre
l'église et l'état s'étaient détériorées
et qu'il convenait de le réparer par un
dialogue en vérité nous espérons
profondément cette réparation du lien
entre l'église catholique et l'état à
plus d'un titre
nous venons de vivre dans la basilique
notre-dame un attentat cet attentat
vient montrer combien l'église
catholique fait partie de la nation et
combien elle est aussi visée comme
partie intégrante de sa culture de son
histoire
et donc c'est la liberté fondamentale
d'exercice des cultes
c'est partie de nos droits issues de la
constitution de la liberté de conscience
de la personne humaine qui convient
aussi une dimension spirituelle le nier
serait effective est contradictoire avec
ce qu'est la france
ces principes merci beaucoup filles
passent au d'avoir répondu ce soir en
direct à nos questions sur rt france